[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
121 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I'm Mark Mandel and I'm here
with my colleague, Melanie
Warrick.
Melanie, how are
you doing today?
MELANIE WARRICK: I'm doing good.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I can hear in
the recording I've definitely
got a gravelly voice from being
sick for the past few weeks.
I'm getting better slowly.
MELANIE WARRICK: You're
surviving somehow.
MARK MANDEL: I'm surviving.
MELANIE WARRICK: I know.
The second wave of the flu has
caught both of us in its wake,
unfortunately.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: But hopefully
this will be out of the woods
soon.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Hopefully.
And the editors will
cut out all my coughing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
Or leave it in for authenticity.
Mark, who are we
talking to this week?
MARK MANDEL: I'm really excited
about the interview this week.
We're talking to one of my
favorite people, Paris Pittman,
program manager for the
Kubernetes community.
And we're also joined
by Garrett Rodrigues
who is a technical program
manager for Google Kubernetes
engine.
We're talking all about how you
can contribute to Kubernetes.
MELANIE WARRICK: Wow.
We never talk about Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: No.
But I like talking about
Kubernetes mostly because
of the alliteration
that I can use with Ks.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Yeah.
And it's a good
episode, especially.
I appreciate it when
we get a chance to talk
about open-source especially.
But before we get
into our interview,
as always, we talk about
our cool things of the week
and our question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So this week comes
from the community.
We were asked about--
we have this wonderful
thing called Cloud Shell.
But sometimes you might want
to use a little bit more power.
So if I need to increase
the power of my Cloud Shell
maybe temporarily,
how do I do that?
MELANIE WARRICK: Well, before we
get into all the other things,
let's talk about the
cool things of the week.
So one of the cool
things of the week
was at the end of last week
there was the TensorFlow Duff
summit.
And this was their
second one and they
had a number of announcements.
And we are going to
include in our show notes,
as always, we'll include
a link that gives you
the highlights from that.
But a couple of things
that stood out especially
were they've announced
TensorFlow Hub, which
is a space that they're using
to help share and allow people
to reuse models that have
been trained and pre-trained
and includes weights.
It allows people to
take that and use
that to improve their own
models for generalization,
or speed up their training.
They've also
announced that they're
supporting more languages
like Swift and JavaScript.
And they have these
additional components
that they've been
building out to help build
a more extensive full scale
machine learning platform
to incorporate things
like Apache Beam.
So there's a number of
resources and links and things.
Oh.
And they're also integrating
with Nvidia's Tensor RT, which
is a library that optimizes deep
learning models for imprints.
I know.
That's a lot of stuff.
It's very cool stuff.
It's all the cool stuff.
MARK MANDEL: That's
all the cool stuff.
MELANIE WARRICK: But we do have
more cool things of the week.
MARK MANDEL: This Tensor
Hub thing looks cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah,.
It's nice to have
actual content that you
can share and reuse and not
have to start from scratch.
OK.
Another cool thing
of the week that's
not TensorFlow machine
learning, there
is the RSA conference
that's coming up.
And that's happening the 16th
through the 20th of April.
And so we have a
link that we're going
to share that we'll announce
the Google Cloud Security
talks that are taking
place during the actual RSA
conference.
Like Ian Goodfellow's going
to be speaking about security
in machine learning.
But we also have our
separate side event
that's going to be
going on that has
a host of a number of different
types of talks around security
that's taking place April 17th
and 18th in San Francisco.
And we were saying
this before, it's
at the Westfield Center,
a.k.a. the Westfield Mall.
So you can go shopping
too apparently.
MARK MANDEL: It's about a
five minute walk from Moscone
apparently.
MELANIE WARRICK: Nice.
Yeah.
All the things.
So yes, we will include
a link for people
to check out what specific
talks are happening and when
and see all the things
around security.
MARK MANDEL: I definitely--
at the RSA conference
there's a thing called
post-quantum cryptography.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: I think I only know
what two of those words mean,
or maybe one of them, post.
MELANIE WARRICK: Post.
And actually, we're going
to be doing a podcast
after this event that's going to
talk a little bit about quantum
security.
But that'll be
later in the month.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: That'll be fun.
All right.
Mark, any cool things
of the week on your end?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
So we were actually
speaking of security.
That's my lovely segue.
There's a really good
blog post that came out
the other day from
- oh, my god, I'm
going to massacre
this last name.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Seems like a thing
we need to do every week now.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MELANIE WARRICK: Which
names can we massacre?
MARK MANDEL: It's just a thing.
Oh, man.
Mayakesarofsky possibly.
They are product manager
for security and privacy.
They do a wonderful article
called "Exploring Container
Security."
So it's an overview of
all the different things
you can do when containerizing
your applications,
particularly running
them on Kubernetes
and the various
layers that you have
that you can apply for
providing security.
Everything from
infrastructure and logging
to secrets, as well as network,
all sorts of other good stuff.
So if you're
building applications
using containers and Kubernetes
for security purposes
you might want to
check that out.
It's really, really nice.
MELANIE WARRICK: Cool.
Anything else that you
wanted to talk about?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Well, since we're
talking about containers,
always, one of our
fellow developer
advocates, [? Mete, ?]
he has written an article
about how to run Windows
containers on Compute Engine.
We don't talk about Windows
often enough, I think.
But it's obviously
a huge ecosystem.
So basically, if you're looking
to run Windows containers
on Compute Engine, he
has a step by step guide
for creating a container
and getting it started,
getting it up and running,
and getting it all going.
There's a little video
in there as well.
So [? Mete ?] does
an excellent job.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
I like stuff that gives you
the step by step and then
also video.
That's a nice value add.
So great.
Well, Mark, shall we go
talk about Kubernetes?
MARK MANDEL: Sure.
Why not?
MELANIE WARRICK: Why not?
MARK MANDEL: So today
I am really excited.
We have two wonderful
people here.
We have Paris Pittman,
co-chair of the contributor
experience special interest
group for Kubernetes,
as well as Garrett
Rodrigues, the technical lead
of the contributor experience
special interest group
for Kubernetes.
Wow.
That was a mouthful.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
How are you both doing?
Paris?
PARIS PITTMAN: I am very well
and very excited to be here.
MARK MANDEL: Garrett,
how are you doing?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
Likewise.
I'm really happy to
be on the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So I'm super happy the two
of you could join us today.
I've been really excited
about this for a long time.
Paris and I work
in the same office.
We get along really well.
So hopefully that comes through.
But we want to talk today about
contributing to Kubernetes,
the experience of like people
who want to come on and get
involved with this product.
And so I thought you two
would be great for doing that.
But before we get
sucked into that,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about both of you
and who you are and what
you do here at Google?
PARIS PITTMAN: I am
on a newly formed team
on Google Cloud
under Sarah Novotni,
managing open source
strategy for the cloud.
My specific area is Kubernetes.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yes.
I'm a technical program manager.
I joined Google about
a year and a half ago.
And I wasn't too familiar
with Kubernetes when I joined.
It was a relatively
small team of engineers.
A group of us we could all
fit in a room at that point.
And since then the
project has taken off,
both in the open source, but in
the number of Google engineers
contributing to it as well.
So I'm very excited to be
part of that massive growth.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yeah.
I definitely consider myself to
be a new contributor as well.
I've only been on
for about six months.
So good, good perspective here.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
OK.
So talking about
contributing to Kubernetes.
Let's take it from a high level.
I'm sure a lot of
people know this,
but I'd love to get your
takes on it as well.
What do you feel is like the
30,000 foot view of Kubernetes
like as a whole?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: OK.
I'll get started.
So it is a complex beast.
I think there's something like
30 special interest groups.
So we organize ourselves--
PARIS PITTMAN: 35.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: 35?
Are you counting
working groups as well?
PARIS PITTMAN: Yes.
I am.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: There
are tiers of contribution.
And we organize ourselves
into special interest groups.
So that's probably a
good place to start.
And these special
interest groups
can come in kind of three
flavors, vertical, horizontal,
or project based.
MARK MANDEL: Not diagonal?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Not diagonal.
MARK MANDEL: I had to ask.
GARRETT RODRIGUES:
So vertical is
like a specific area within
the Kubernetes ecosystem.
You can think of it as like
a technical area of focus.
Node might be one.
Networking might be
another, Kubernetes API.
Horizontal may be
something that encompasses
many SIGs, like
architecture, I think is one.
And then project is
something like what we do,
which is contributor
experience, or SIG release,
which are dedicated to kind of
improving how you get started
contributing to the
project, or SIG release
into making sure that we
have stable, well tested,
well documented, releases
on a regular cadence.
PARIS PITTMAN: And
just to echo the large,
we do have 52 repositories under
the Kubernetes organization
on GitHub, which is very large.
And that includes
core, and core here
would be Kubernetes Kubernetes.
So then we're talking about
a very, very large ecosystem
of things that are
being built on top of.
So when people talk about
contributing to Kubernetes
you really do have
to kind of get down
into the granular ask
of contributing what
and where to Kubernetes.
Because that could
be a lot of things
in a lot of different repos.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It sounds scary.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yes.
Definitely.
And I think that contributor
experience has been working
on ways to not make that scary.
GARRETT RODRIGUES:
Make it less scary.
PARIS PITTMAN: Definitely
less scary, more sustainable,
maintainable, and making
sure that the contributor has
as much of a similar to same
process across those repos
as possible, which can
definitely be a challenge.
Because some of those repos are,
you know, essentially different
projects and may also
have different workflows.
So Garrett and myself and
LC, who's another co-chair,
and many, many other folks in
the contributor experience SIG
have been working on
issues just like that.
MARK MANDEL: So we keep using
this word SIG, special interest
group.
What is this thing?
PARIS PITTMAN: It's
really a way to break down
the project, maintain
code ownership,
which is something that we
are trying to undergo right
now with a lot of things that
the Steering Committee has been
pushing now as far as
standardization of SIGs and SIG
charters.
And therefore, you know,
claiming code ownership
with that.
But the special interest
groups are really
pushing the vision for
their area of the project.
So for instance, SIG
networking, SIG node,
those are some of
our larger groups.
And push different
projects related
to those special interests.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
As the projects
scale, one more time,
coming back to
massive, massive scale,
we've been focusing more on
how we organize the project.
And SIGs was kind of the
natural way of doing it.
I think that was formed prior to
me joining the project in 2016.
And the idea is
that these SIGs are
responsible for various
areas and they're
forced to talk to
each other when
they have cross dependencies
within the project.
More recently, we've been
defining the governance
in greater detail.
I think within
the last few weeks
we've been talking about
splitting the roles out
into chairs for the SIG.
People that are technical leads
and similar to TLs at Google,
who are responsible for
kind of the oversight
of the overall
interest of the SIG.
And then sub-project leads,
who drive individual projects
within a special interest group.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And who runs it?
Who runs a SIG?
PARIS PITTMAN: Anyone
who's nominated.
Right now, I mean,
each SIG already
has leads, and now chairs.
The lead to chair title change
is actually very recent,
as of I believe it's a week ago.
But these chairs
ultimately run the SIG.
And they were vetted through
some kind of nomination process
at that time of creation.
So for instance, if you're
in the project right now
and you have the idea for a
SIG, you would propose the SIG
on the K-Dev, and K-Dev meaning
Kubernetes development mailing
list.
And pretty much nominate
either yourself or other people
to run it.
And then you would ultimately
get nominated through Plus One
system.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
And when you say
run the SIG, there
are so many facets
to that as well.
There's driving
technical projects.
But then there are
the day to day things
that come up with running
your project that service
contributors from
all over the world.
So it's things like making sure
that our milestones are well
published, our roadmap,
our goals for the quarter,
our goals for release, are
published in agreement,
that videos are
uploaded to YouTube,
so people who can't
make the meeting times
are able to discover
them, making sure
that there are meeting notes,
making sure that information
is communicated widely.
And that's done across various
members of the Kubernetes
community.
The chair handles some of it.
Tech leads are responsible
for some of it.
So it's just a matter
of working together
in kind of a very
large, large community.
MARK MANDEL: Do all SIGs
have the same structure?
Or does it vary from SIG to SIG?
PARIS PITTMAN: It definitely
varies from SIG to SIG.
I think we're going to start
seeing more standardization now
that the Steering
Committee has weighed
on things like charter
templates and other kind
of uniform procedures.
But it really just depends
on what that SIG needs.
So if the SIG doesn't have a
need for technical guidance,
then they don't necessarily
have a technical lead.
But the template that
the Steering Committee
has pushed down is more of
guidance than it is a mandate.
So you know, it's
just to each SIG,
you know, their own, if
you will, on those matters.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
But you bring up a great
point, which is consistency.
And that's something that
ContribX and the Steering
Committee and a
lot of other people
who have been around
the project for a while
have been focusing on, which
is, how do we make sure
that moving from
one SIG to another,
or moving from one
repo to another,
you get kind of a
consistent experience
when you're contributing.
So first SIGs, very
recently, we've
merged the charter template.
And if you go into
the community repo.
So It's Kubernetes
slash community.
It's a GitHub repository.
You can actually see
that template starting
to get filled out for a number
of the 35 SIGs that call out,
you know, who the chair
is, who the technical lead
is, what the subprojects are.
They're all done
declaratively, which
is another theme in Kubernetes.
So that there's-- there's
an audit trail and you can
actually see the state
of the world in the repo.
MELANIE WARRICK: So
I'm new to Kubernetes.
And let's say I
want to contribute.
What would be my first step?
PARIS PITTMAN: First step is
to check the Contributor Guide.
That's always a
very good easy way
of getting a sort of
beginner checklist.
The contributor guide lives
now on the community repo
under contributor and
inside of the guide folder.
MARK MANDEL: We'll put
links in the show notes.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yes.
Of course.
And the guide actually has a
great story behind it, which
we can get to in a second.
But we have some awesome
community members
that have been pushing out this
new style of Contributor Guide.
Previously, we had just
our growing community
help us with contributor
documentation, which, you know,
now has issues of just
docs getting outdated,
links going bad,
things like that.
So now we are starting to
centralize that process
under that contributor folder.
But the Contributor
Guide's a great first step.
Because then you'll
see things like how
to sign the CLA, what
our labeling system looks
like on GitHub, how to set
up your dev environment,
and to just get the really
basic things right there.
I think a good second
step is to join the Slack.
The Slack is very robust,
with 30,000 people on it,
that means contributors
as well as users, which
equals Kubernetes community.
And then also mailing lists
of certain SIGs and things
like that.
And there is a SIG list
also in the community repo
as well, that will be
linked to the show notes.
MARK MANDEL: I mean, that sounds
like so much information as
well, which is great.
Thank you, Paris.
So if I am coming to
contribute to Kubernetes,
do you think I
should be focusing on
like a specific SIG?
Like do I do that?
Where's my entry point?
Do you know what I mean?
PARIS PITTMAN: Your entry
point depends on you, I think.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
PARIS PITTMAN: And I think our
experienced developers, who
for instance, already
have Go experience,
may already know where
their value add is.
So for instance, if
they really love IPv6
and that's their thing
then they would probably
know to go to some kind of
networking group in which they
would find out on the
SIG list that, hey, there
is a SIG networking.
Let's be a fly on the
wall on their mailing
list and their Slack
channel and kind of see
what's up from there.
Or another entry
point which we've
seen a lot of people come
in from is documentation.
As a user they see
that the docs are wrong
and they plug-in from
that perspective.
And then the
Contributor Guide story
is actually one
very much like that.
I was here for a month
and knew at the time
that the Contributor
Guide was a high priority.
But again, here for a
month, deer in headlights.
Hi.
It's Google.
It's Kubernetes.
And I had a woman
come to me through
various different channels.
And she said, "Hey,
I'm a new contributor.
I just started at Samsung."
Her name's Gwen.
Shout out to Gwen.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Hey, Gwen.
PARIS PITTMAN: Hey, your
Contributor Guide really sucks.
What's up with this?
And I said, one,
welcome to open source.
Submit a pull request.
Two, I'm so glad to hear
that you're on board
and passionate
about contributing.
And hey, we really need
somebody to help us
with this Contributor Guide.
And here we are.
We have an MVP for Contributor
Guide from Gwen and company.
So--
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yeah.
Absolutely.
That's one of the things
we talk about all the time
in the Kubernetes community.
I think they've even
giving out awards
at some of the Kube cons for
chopping wood and carrying
water.
There's a lot of work.
And there's a lot of really
exciting feature work
to be done in Kubernetes.
But everyone's got
to start somewhere.
And I think a good way
to learn our process is
to get involved with,
like Paris said,
some of the documentation work.
Testing is a great
place to get involved.
If I were getting started
for the first time ever,
I would probably
try and get, you
know, hope that I found my way
to the Kubernetes community
repo.
That way I can see the
organization of the project.
From there you can
find all of the SIGs
and all of their meeting times.
Another really valuable
resource in there
if you want to get started
and learn like Kubernetes
and like the history
is all the design
proposals are in
there too, broken down
by special interest group.
So if you go, I think, it's
in the contributor folder.
We can at this link as
well to the podcast.
But all the design
proposals are there.
And if you said,
you know, you're
interested in the networking
SIG, or the node SIG,
you can see like a history
of all the design proposals.
You can even look at the
code reviews going into them
and some of the discussions
surrounding them.
So it's a good
place to kind of get
some of that
technical information
and see the discussions
kind of happening.
PARIS PITTMAN: It's important
to note that finding a SIG
should not be the
most important thing
to do the first time you
contribute to Kubernetes.
You really keep find
your entrance point.
And there are as, you know, we
just laid out here multiple.
I mean, even another
just standard
GitHub entry point., if you
will, is just our labels.
We have the help wanted label.
Some of the repos are
using good first time
or for new contributors.
And that's again,
that's also something
that Garrett and
I are working on
and other folks in the
contributor experience group
to get labels standardized
across the board
and have other repos use things
like good first time issue
or help wanted consistently.
But there are definitely
repos right there
that use all of the above.
So if you are,
like I said before,
an experienced contributor
you can indeed just jump right
in through issues.
MARK MANDEL: Actually we've
mentioned it a couple of times.
I just kind of want to
highlight it as well.
Many, all, I don't know,
the SIGs they run meetings.
So there's actual in-person
meetings that you can go to.
It's not just all online.
Is that correct?
PARIS PITTMAN: That's correct.
The SIGs do have their
regular online meetings,
which are either weekly,
bi-weekly depending
on their cadence,
or nightly, hourly,
depending on some of them.
I feel like we're
releasing so much.
You wonder if they
are meeting hourly.
No.
But then we also do face to
face meetings at Kube Con.
And now we have three Kube
cons a year, so one in Seattle,
one in Copenhagen, one in China.
And there they have 30 minute
update sessions, as well as
deep dive sessions.
And then they also do face to
face meetings, most of them
do at this point anyway.
And that's just coming
together at least
annually just to get
stuff done and set things
and depending on
what their needs are.
Like for instance, helm
just had a helm summit.
Shout out to the helm crew.
But, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So if I'm
a new contributor should
I go to one of these meetings?
Or is this just for
the experienced people?
PARIS PITTMAN: I would
say that probably wouldn't
be your best entrance point.
But I think the SIG
updates at Kube Con
would be awesome for that.
I wouldn't necessarily
say the face
to face, because like
I said, that's really
where they're doing deep
dives into some of the issues
that they're working on.
For instance, storage
had one in Q4 last year.
And they really
concentrated heavily
on CSI, the CSI implementation,
and it's like that.
So I think newcomers might
be lost to that conversation.
But definitely the
updates for sure.
I mean, that's where we
owe the community an update
of what we've been doing.
There's also the
contributor summit
as well, that we have now.
Where it's all
contributors and we're
going to be building out
a new contributor track.
George Castro with Hep TO
and several other people,
myself, are planning that.
So that'll be a
good time as well.
MARK MANDEL: Is that
a separate event?
Or is that part of a Kube Con?
That's technically
a separate event,
technically a part of Kube Con.
They're calling it
a co-located event.
It is on May Day for
Copenhagen, so May 1st.
And it is free and no
you don't need a ticket
to Kube Con to attend.
So if you are a new contributor
and listening right now,
please feel free to
go to the website.
It's a Google form.
That's why it's a Google form
and not through the website.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: As we
mentioned all of the community
stuff, I think we missed the
elephant in the room, which is
the weekly community meeting.
I'm not sure that
we mentioned that.
That's probably the best place
to get the state of the worlds.
And that's more at a
project wide level.
We talk about all
the SIG meetings.
Everything is hosted on Zoom.
But every Thursday at
10:00 AM Pacific time,
there's a Kubernetes
community meeting.
And we talk about things
like the current release.
There's usually a
demo of a product
or project within
Kubernetes, or something
that runs on top of Kubernetes.
So you kind of get a feel of how
people are using the project.
And there's also SIG
updates there as well.
So that's a really good place
to kind of get a 10,000 foot
view of the state of the world.
MELANIE WARRICK:
How does somebody
get to demo at that meeting?
PARIS PITTMAN: There is a agenda
document on the calendar invite
that you can find on
kubernetes.io/community.
And in the agenda
at the top, you just
pretty much add your
name to the demo list.
I think right now we're
probably into May on that list.
It's-- yeah-- definitely, if
you're out there listening
to and want to demo to at least
300 plus people weekly get
on now.
MARK MANDEL: Very cool.
So even if I'm just
a user of Kubernetes
that actually sounds like it
could just be useful as well.
PARIS PITTMAN: Oh, for sure.
Definitely.
I mean, I think--
I think we really want users to
be as much into our community
as possible.
I think a lot of people
think community just
means contributors.
But users should plug-in
because then they'll
be able to see what
we are rolling out,
as far as innovations and
features and things like that.
So they are prepared
ahead of time.
And that's the best place
to get that information.
MELANIE WARRICK: Before you were
saying something about Helm.
What is Helm?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Helm?
Sure.
It falls under SIG apps, which
is short for applications.
And it is a package
manager for Kubernetes.
So it's an easier way
to customize and deploy
applications.
They have a bunch of, I
guess what they call charts.
I'm not too involved
with SIG apps.
So I'm probably doing a poor
job of explaining right now.
PARIS PITTMAN: You're
doing wonderful.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: But
for more information
there are a couple of repos.
There's the helm repo
and the charts repo.
You can see all the
applications they have there.
So if you want to get started
installing MySQL or a WordPress
application, Helm
is one of the ways
that you can actually do that.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yeah.
That's one of 52 repos in
that gigantic organization
on GitHub.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: That's crazy.
So I've done some work
doing small contributions
inside Kubernetes.
I've noticed a lot
of it's automated.
There's a lot of build tools
and build bots and things
like that.
Can you tell us a
little bit about how
that whole system works?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Absolutely.
That's sort of where I
jumped in on the project.
So there's a SIG dedicated
to tooling and automation.
And it's going to
be SIG testing.
And they own what's called the
test infrastructure repository.
And as the project
scaled it became
really important to make
sure that the processes were
streamlined.
You can imagine with 3,000
plus contributors, if someone
had to manually merge your
PR after doing a code review
and doing that across
so many contributors,
would be time consuming
and bottlenecks would
appear all over the place.
So we tried to leverage
some of the experience
from other large
open source projects,
from Google internally to
manage the code review process.
So that we require
code review from people
who are more experienced.
We require people to demonstrate
ownership over certain areas
within the project.
So there's actually two tiers of
code review that are required.
There's LGTM, which is sort
of like a stylistic review
and making sure that your code
fits within the Kubernetes
contributing standards.
And then there's
approval as well,
which is someone who is really
familiar with that section
of the repository.
So someone who owns the
node team, kind of a TL from
like the node side or
the networking side,
or wherever you're contributing,
to also approve the changes.
After two people have indicated
their levels of approval, two
or more, it's actually-- it
can be more complex than that.
So it's worth reading
the Contributor Guide.
There's actually automation
that will automatically
recognize that you have
sufficient approval.
And then magically
merge your PR.
So you get put into
a summit queue.
Everything is kind
of batch tested.
There is a suite of tests that
must pass, pre-submit tests.
And when that's
done and successful,
your code is merged.
There are lots more
requirements depending
on the time of the quarter.
So if it's during what's
called code freeze, which we're
actually in right now,
only testing fixes
should be getting in.
So no features can get in.
There's kind of a complex
process for contributing.
And again, this is why
we have that very long,
complex Contributor Guide.
But the idea is to spell
it out and make things
as efficiently as possible.
PARIS PITTMAN: You
can actually see
on Dev Stats, which is a project
that Garrett helped kick off,
it's kates.devstats.cncf.io.
Another link that
we'll give you.
But this is an awesome way to
check the stats of the project.
But you can actually
see, I just wanted
to shout that out, you can
actually see some of the issues
start to level off as we
started to increase automation
on certain areas.
And add in things like bot
labeling and things like that.
So that's really kind of how
we're measuring too, you know,
is this stuff working.
MELANIE WARRICK: Why are you
guys in code freeze right now?
GARRETT RODRIGUES: So we
are just before a release.
The last month of the
quarter, generally, we
prepare for the minor
release of Kubernetes.
I believe it's releasing
Wednesday, March 26.
You know the date?
PARIS PITTMAN: Sounds
good enough to me.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: So
the last four weeks
are dedicated to stabilization.
So the quarter is
generally broken up
with seven or eight
weeks of development
time, where features
are being submitted
and there's feature
work being done.
And then we work on making
sure that all of those tests
are passing before
cutting new release.
PARIS PITTMAN: Oh.
And plug for the release
team for new contributors
and current contributors.
They have rules
on every release.
And even new contributors
can take the third seat role
to kind of see what's going
on in the lay of the land.
So that they could step
up for other releases.
MARK MANDEL: So it
sounds like there's
opportunities there to
contribute to Kubernetes
itself, its
documentation, as well
as all its automation
and release processing
across the board.
PARIS PITTMAN: That is right.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Yes.
Absolutely.
MELANIE WARRICK:
And there's mentors.
We were talking about
briefly you also
have mentors that
people can work with.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yes.
Right now I'm building
out it's, I think,
we're at four to five
programs right now all
in an incubation phase.
Incubation because a lot of
the programs that were running
are either A, new
to Kubernetes or B,
new to mentoring and
open source in general,
like the concept of group
mentoring in open source.
So we're testing all of
those things out right now.
But if you are interested
in anything mentoring
related or to be a
part of the tests,
there is a mentoring folder
in the community repo as well.
And you can check the
Read Me out there.
MELANIE WARRICK: What's
your favorite color?
GARRETT RODRIGUES:
Kubernetes blue.
PARIS PITTMAN:
Black, like my soul.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh.
I like we need to have
a therapy session now.
MARK MANDEL: Is there
anything we haven't mentioned?
You want to make sure you
get in any events coming up
or any special things going on?
Or really just anything at
all, your favorite dogs?
I'm totally OK with that too.
PARIS PITTMAN: So as part
of the mentoring deal,
one of the tests
that we're running
is a monthly series called
Meet Our Contributors.
It's sort of mentors
on demand, if you will.
So we're trying to solve for
time on everybody's part there.
And we have between four
to seven contributors
monthly come on for two
different time zones.
And we essentially
live stream on YouTube
and ask questions from the
Meet Our Contributors Slack
channel as well as Twitter.
And it's pretty much
anything from what
is your favorite color,
to the contributor,
to how the heck
do EDE tests work?
I'm very confused.
My tests are failing.
So it's literally anything
that you'd like to ask.
And again, that's the first
Wednesday of the month.
And you can get a copy of the
calendar via the community
website on the Kubernetes site.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
Paris, Garrett,
thank you so much for
hanging out with us
and spending time with
us and talking to us
all about contributing
to Kubernetes.
PARIS PITTMAN: Yay!
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
Thank you.
GARRETT RODRIGUES: Fantastic.
Awesome.
Thanks for having us.
PARIS PITTMAN: Thank you
so much for having us.
MARK MANDEL: So thanks
again to Paris and Garrett
for joining us today.
I love chatting
about Kubernetes,
love talking about open source.
I hope that's a useful
thing for anyone who's
looking to get involved with
the Kubernetes ecosystem,
write some code, write
some documentation,
just get stuck in.
MELANIE WARRICK: Definitely.
It was good to get all the
insights around Kubernetes
and how to be involved in it.
So Mark?
MARK MANDEL:
Question of the week.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: So thanks out to
one of our community members,
Justin Garrison.
He sent in a wonderfully
interesting question,
actually, that I
didn't even know
existed, which was super cool.
So the question
was basically, if I
need to temporarily increase
the power of the Cloud Shell VM,
how do I do that?
So maybe I'm doing
some extra processing
or I want to do something that's
computationally intensive,
what do I do?
MELANIE WARRICK: So there's a
boost mode that you can use.
And that's something you can
find very easily in the Cloud
Shell section.
And so when you choose
that, it apparently
will temporarily increase the
power of your Cloud Shell VM
from a default G1
small machine type
offering to an N1
standard one VM instance.
So yeah, you just
press a button.
MARK MANDEL: So like basically,
I'm going back to my childhood
and remembering the turbo
button on my computer.
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
It feels like it should
be called turbo and red.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Like totally.
And you just left it on.
Like I just left on turbo.
Like I was ever like why
would you turn this off.
It's worth noting
though, once activated,
all sessions will be boosted
for the next 24 hours.
And enabling boost mode will
restart your Cloud Shell
and immediately
terminate your session.
So just be prepared for that.
It is an experimental feature.
So additional limits may be
implemented in the future.
But if you need that kind of
power it's there and available,
which is kind of cool.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Yes, definitely.
MARK MANDEL: I love Cloud Shell.
MELANIE WARRICK:
Fun and effective.
Well, Mark, so this
past weekend we
had April Fools, and Easter,
and a blue moon all at once.
Did you do anything
fun for all of it?
MARK MANDEL: I was really sick.
So I stayed home.
MELANIE WARRICK: So you slept.
MARK MANDEL: Did you
see anything cool
and happy and exciting?
MELANIE WARRICK: I saw some
people wearing some funny hats.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
MELANIE WARRICK: That was cute.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
MELANIE WARRICK: Lots of
fun hats out there actually.
Well, I hope everybody
had a good one.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Are you up to anything
exciting or interesting
coming up in the next few weeks?
MELANIE WARRICK: Yes.
I will be speaking about AI at a
training camp called Techtonica
on April 11th.
And then I'm also going
to be participating
in a panel on
diversity inclusion
at the Harker Research
Symposium on April 14th.
Mark, are you going
to be anywhere?
MARK MANDEL: No, actually.
So I just finished up with GDC.
So now I actually have to
plan out the rest of my year.
So I'm going to have to do that.
I know what I'm doing.
MELANIE WARRICK: Unfortunately,
you've been sick.
But I mean, did you technically
get some rest and some downtime
after GDC?
MARK MANDEL: I did.
I took a couple of days off.
So it's been-- it's been good.
So I will get better
soon, I promise.
MELANIE WARRICK: Oh, good.
Well, I think that's
it for us this week.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Well, Melanie, thank you
very much for joining me
for yet another
episode of the podcast.
MELANIE WARRICK: Thank you.
MARK MANDEL: And thank you,
everyone, for listening.
And we'll see you all next week.